dacă rotești o minge în jurul unui ax și apoi al altuia, nu e același lucru cu cele două rotații în ordine inversă
astăzi, în Qiskit în clasă, vom vedea ce legătură are această minge cu calculatoarele cuantice și unul dintre cele mai celebre
principii din mecanica cuantică: principiul incertitudinii
bun venit la Qiskit în clasă, o serie de videoclipuri în care defalcăm un concept fundamental pe care
l-ai putea întâlni într-un curs legat de Quantum Computing; fiecare videoclip este însoțit de un modul interactiv, cu linkul în
descrierea de mai jos, așa că nu uita să-l consulți; astăzi vorbim despre principiul incertitudinii Heisenberg; dacă
ai mai auzit de el, poate ai auzit și gluma veche despre Heisenberg: într-o zi a fost tras pe dreapta în timp ce conducea și polițistul l-a întrebat: știi
cu ce viteză mergeai? Heisenberg a răspuns: nu, dar știu exact unde mă aflu; cam asta e
principiul incertitudinii lui Heisenberg pe scurt: nu poți ști simultan poziția și impulsul unei particule
cu precizie perfectă; se scrie de obicei astfel: Delta x înmulțit cu Delta p este mai mare sau
egal cu h/ 2, unde Delta X și Delta P sunt
incertitudinile în poziție și impuls, iar H este o constantă fundamentală minusculă din mecanica cuantică
Heisenberg a formulat această inegalitate în 1927, imaginându-și cum să măsoare poziția unui electron; dacă
ai reflecta un foton de pe el ca să vezi unde se află, acel foton ar lovi inevitabil electronul și i-ar perturba
impulsul; aceasta nu e doar o afirmație despre faptul că măsurătorile perturbă un sistem: ne spune că există limite fundamentale
în ceea ce putem afla despre natură; acesta e un exemplu dintr-un principiu mai larg numit complementaritate, care
spune că anumite aspecte ale naturii sunt incompatibile între ele și nu pot fi observate
simultan; de exemplu, obiectele cuantice se comportă uneori ca particule și uneori ca unde,
dar nu poți observa ambele comportamente simultan; relația lui Heisenberg dintre poziție și impuls a acoperit doar una dintre
multele perechi de caracteristici complementare; această incertitudine intrinsecă are legătură cu modul în care privim proprietăți precum
poziția și impulsul în mecanica cuantică; în loc să ne gândim la X și P ca la variabile sau proprietăți intrinseci
pe care fiecare particulă le posedă, în mecanica cuantică poziția și impulsul sunt operatori; nu sunt proprietăți ale unui
sistem, ci lucruri pe care le poți face unui sistem; a afla acum poziția unei particule îți cere să efectuezi o
operație asupra sistemului și să faci o măsurătoare; această operație poate influența rezultatul altor operații ulterioare
ca analogie, gândește-te la o bucată de lemn uscat; are multe proprietăți, precum
poziția, dimensiunea, forma; are și proprietatea de a putea fi arsă și de a putea pluti pe apă; dacă acest lemn ar fi un
obiect cuantic, acestea nu ar fi proprietăți pe care le-ai putea cunoaște a priori; în schimb, spunem că sunt
observabile: lucruri pe care le poți afla despre sistem dacă efectuezi o operație asupra lui; deci ar trebui să aplici
operatorul de ardere sau de plutire, ceea ce ar necesita să încerci efectiv să arzi lemnul sau să-l pui în
apă ca să vezi dacă plutește; rezultatul fiecăruia dintre acești operatori depinde de ordinea în care îi aplici; dacă
testezi mai întâi arderea, lemnul se va arde în cenușă și nu vei putea testa dacă plutește; dar dacă testezi
mai întâi plutirea, atunci va fi prea ud ca să ardă; spunem că operatorii de ardere și
de plutire nu comutează: ordinea operațiilor contează; aceasta duce la o limită fundamentală
în cât de bine pot fi cunoscute aceste două observabile despre bucata de lemn, deoarece nu putem spune cu certitudine dacă
arde sau plutește fără a cunoaște contextul măsurătorii; desigur, cu o bucată reală de lemn
ai putea-o tăia în două și testa ambele proprietăți simultan, dar nu poți face ceva similar cu o particulă cuantică; această
analogie cu lemnul este doar atât: o analogie; incertitudinea e ceva specific cuantic; X și P nu comutează nici ele
și această proprietate de necomutativitate este cea care duce la principiul incertitudinii lui Heisenberg; în general, oricare doi operatori
care nu comutează vor avea propriul lor principiu al incertitudinii; forma generală a principiului incertitudinii poate fi
scrisă astfel: Delta a înmulțit cu Delta
B este mai mare sau egal cu
1/2 înmulțit cu există a și b, unde
această paranteză se numește
comutator și este egal cu diferența dintre aplicarea mai întâi a lui a, apoi
B, și aplicarea mai întâi a lui B, apoi a; aceste paranteze unghiulare
semnalează că iei ceea ce se numește valoarea de așteptare a ceea ce se află înăuntru; practic, dacă ai face aceeași
măsurătoare de foarte multe ori, valoarea de așteptare este valoarea medie a tuturor acelor măsurători; astăzi vom
testa și verifica efectiv acest principiu al incertitudinii pe un calculator cuantic IBM; vom analiza trei observabile diferite
ale unui qubit, vom arăta că operatorii lor nu comutează și, în final, vom putea demonstra că
principiul incertitudinii se verifică pentru aceste observabile ale qubit-ului; mai întâi, o scurtă paranteză despre o modalitate utilă de a vizualiza starea cuantică
a unui qubit; aceasta poate fi reprezentată printr-un vector care indică un punct pe o sferă numită sfera Bloch; am acoperit
acest subiect într-un videoclip anterior, cu linkul în descriere, dar îți voi da și o scurtă recapitulare aici; iată
sfera Bloch; fiecare vector este parametrizat prin două unghiuri: Theta și Fi
starea zero se află la Polul Nord, iar starea unu la Polul Sud; o superpozitie egală de 0 și unu se află
undeva pe Ecuator, unde Fi este egal cu faza relativă dintre cele două componente ale
superpozitiei; deci această stare de aici ar fi egală
cu 1 / rădăcina din 2 ori 0 + e la puterea i Fi ori 1, unde i este acea
fază; când măsurăm o observabilă a qubit-ului, rezultatul este întotdeauna una dintre două opțiuni, corespunzătoare celor două
stări posibile ale qubit-ului; pentru experimentul pe care urmează să-l facem, vom analiza trei observabile și
operatorii lor corespondenți X, Y și Z; când măsori oricare dintre aceste observabile, obții fie plus unu, fie
minus unu, cu o probabilitate pentru fiecare care depinde de unghiul dintre vectorul qubit-ului pe sfera Bloch și
WEBVTT
axa de măsurare; după cum te-ai putea aștepta, Z măsoară de-a lungul axei Z, X de-a lungul lui X
și Y de-a lungul lui Y; acum amintește-ți că vorbim despre observabile, deoarece cu un sistem
cuantic nu mai putem pur și simplu să știm lucruri despre sistem fără să le măsurăm
și fiecare observabilă are o operație corespunzătoare, deoarece măsurătorile necesită operații; poate că nu e evident, dar
se dovedește că operatorii corespunzători fiecăreia dintre aceste observabile x, y și z sunt
rotații de Pi în jurul axelor lor respective; deci X este o rotație în jurul lui X, Y
în jurul lui Y, iar Z în jurul lui Z; deci, pentru a vedea dacă acești operatori comutează sau nu, putem verifica dacă rotațiile
pe o sferă comutează; dacă da, principiul incertitudinii nu se va aplica și am putea cunoaște X, Y și Z ale unui qubit
cu precizie perfectă; dacă nu comutează, vom putea găsi o nouă relație de incertitudine pentru qubit; urmărește
punctul de pe această minge în timp ce rotesc mai întâi în jurul lui X și apoi în jurul lui Y: ajunge
aici; acum să încercăm în ordine inversă: rotesc mai întâi în jurul lui Y și
apoi în jurul lui X; ajunge dincolo; deci cu siguranță nu comutează, ceea ce înseamnă
că nu putem cunoaște simultan valorile exacte X, Y și Z ale unui qubit; vom avea o
relație de incertitudine; vom trece peste detalii, dar ajungem la trei relații de incertitudine diferite
deci avem Delta x înmulțit cu Delta Y
mai mare sau egal cu Z; Delta Y ori Delta Z mai mare sau egal
cu X; și Delta Z ori Delta X mai mare sau egal
cu Y; deci produsul oricăror două incertitudini este întotdeauna mai mare sau
egal cu valoarea de așteptare a celei de-a treia observabile; hai să folosim Qiskit ca să vedem ce
se întâmplă când încercăm să măsurăm atât Z, cât și X pentru starea zero; măsurarea lui Z e simplă: e baza standard
a calculatorului cuantic; măsurătorile sunt întotdeauna de-a lungul lui Z în mod implicit; dar pentru a măsura X trebuie să efectuăm ceva numit
schimbare de bază: practic rotim sfera Bloch astfel încât X să indice acum în sus unde Z indica înainte; pentru aceasta
folosim un Hadamard gate; deci circuit-ul cuantic complet va arăta astfel: măsurăm pe Z, aplicăm Hadamard
și apoi măsurăm pe X; dacă folosim Qiskit Primitive sampler pentru a rula acest experiment de multe ori, obținem
o histogramă a rezultatelor măsurătorilor care arată astfel pentru măsurătoarea Z
și astfel pentru măsurătoarea pe X; deci, după cum poți vedea, am măsurat
qubit-ul ca aflându-se în starea zero de-a lungul lui Z cu o certitudine apropiată de 100%, dar
de-a lungul lui X nu știam practic nimic despre starea qubit-ului; a fost măsurat ca zero sau unu cu probabilitate egală,
ceea ce înseamnă că incertitudinea noastră în X era cât mai mare posibil; asta ne oferă
o idee despre acest compromis al incertitudinilor, dar putem merge puțin mai departe pe calculatorul nostru cuantic; putem folosi un
Qiskit Primitive numit estimator pentru a găsi valorile de așteptare ale observabilelor noastre X, Y și Z și
incertitudinea în fiecare; hai să-l încercăm pentru starea care indică în direcția plus X pe sfera Bloch; vom folosi estimator
pentru a calcula incertitudinile în x și z pentru această stare și valoarea de așteptare a lui
y; cu această stare, obținem acest rezultat din Qiskit; când luăm produsul celor două
incertitudini în X și Y, vedem că, după cum era de așteptat, este mai mare decât valoarea absolută
a valorii de așteptare a lui Y; dar aceasta a fost doar pentru o stare particulară; vrem să ne asigurăm că această inegalitate
se verifică pentru toate stările qubit-ului; deci hai să folosim din nou estimator, dar de data aceasta îl vom ruga să parcurgă valorile unui
parametru și să găsească valorile de așteptare la fiecare valoare a parametrului pe care i-o dăm; parametrul pe care vrem să-l
parcurgem este unghiul Theta pe sfera Bloch, astfel încât să verificăm inegalitatea pentru toate stările qubit-ului care se află pe
acest arc care intersectează planul XZ; când facem asta, obținem un grafic în funcție de unghiul Theta; curba roșie
este produsul celor două incertitudini, iar curba portocalie este valoarea de așteptare a lui Y; după cum era de așteptat,
produsul incertitudinilor în x și z este mult mai mare decât valoarea de așteptare a lui Y; dar aceasta nu era
prea greu de satisfăcut inegalitatea, deoarece valoarea de așteptare a lui Y era atât de mică: era zero pentru toate stările pe
acest arc; hai să facem un parcurs similar prin valorile lui Theta, dar în loc să parcurgem în planul XZ, vom seta Fi egal cu pi/
4, deci ne uităm la stările qubit-ului care se află pe un arc diferit pe sferă; aici vedem că inegalitatea este
testată un pic mai serios, deoarece curba portocalie și curba roșie sunt mai aproape una de alta, dar roșia este întotdeauna deasupra portocaliei
și principiul incertitudinii se menține în continuare; nu am verificat toate stările încă, dar sperăm că începi să înțelegi
ideea: există o necunoscutitate fundamentală despre oricare două aspecte complementare ale unui sistem cuantic,
inclusiv acest qubit pe care l-am folosit; principiul incertitudinii ne obligă să confruntăm faptul că, indiferent
cât de mult ne străduim, indiferent cât de ingenioase sunt măsurătorile noastre, nu vom ști niciodată totul cu precizie perfectă
nu există nicio cale de a ocoli asta, cu adevărat; dacă nu mă crezi, sau chiar dacă mă crezi, te provoc: du-te și consulta modulul
cu linkul în descriere și încearcă să învingi principiul incertitudinii; mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare